So my son went to work with me today,
and he decided that he wanted to do some Christmas shopping
for his brothers and sisters.
So
he had a little bit of spending money for working with me for the day.
He did actually work really hard,
and he's. He's a part of the age where I can teach him how to work.
So this is perfect.
I was already inspired by the videos of Christmas shopping
and thrifting instead of going to target and buying all brand new toys
or wherever you shop for Christmas presents.
And normally I kind of avoid the toy section at goodwill
because the kids just wanna overload my house with toys.
And we are very minimal toy house.
We don't have toys out. We have, like,
Legos and then a few personal toys,
and that is it. If the kids can't pick it up in, like,
five minutes after asking to clean their rooms,
then it doesn't stay. But it's Christmas,
and my son wants to get into the.
The spirit of giving.
So we're gonna get some Christmas toys from the thrift store.
And I don't know how long these are gonna last in the house,
but it's gonna be great on Christmas Day.
The kids are gonna have fun and enjoy these toys.
And I will say this was extremely cheap.
We got enough toys for all the kids for $50